pace is important Jim and they're going
to slow it down a little bit
for UConn there's Hawkins he pulls up
and fires it just like he did Saturday
he hits his opening shot of the game and
what mints would it be ever so careful
to not draw a foolish first foul is how
they call it that's something they are
concerned with especially against the
size of Sunoco who hits his first shot
Newton racing ahead that's tremel who
knocked it out of his hands nice cut the
Jackson
constant movement right there Jackson
always seems to be in the right place at
the right time launching on April 11th
[Applause]
shot wow
a pig Newton Jackson on Bradley got to
stay close likes to bounce get that side
step three nice roller to go who's there
but sunogo and he's everywhere a row how
about sunogo on the open we talked about
his offensive footwork defensively he's
become a tuned alert
Yukon with that deep bench still with
the five starters on the floor right now
Central on the floor now great shooter
well they're pushing it two even if you
don't get a pass break you've got some
plenty of time to run your offense this
is the guy that passes and finds me back
to the floor with it that ball hit a leg
and sunogo lost a shoe they're out of
sync at that end have been for now
almost eight minutes Mark has got to get
busy a little bit nice pass
it was trying to block it down on the
blocks Caravan is behind himself
he didn't need to make shoot it he had a
good look he had Caravan it looked like
tells the story here to this point in
the first half
[Applause]
goes for rhythm isn't the same but
walking by in the game and he's taken
over this
double
driving in can't get by that guy Jackson
there's Newton taking off again after
the turnover driving in and bringing it
in for two more
being inside Newton's on a hot shot he's
got another one this time of three and
once again Jackson with the push running
like they have all tournament long
running away from everybody
so they're going to Stir It Up on this
end of the floor
excellent coming around the screen by
sunogo
[Applause]
they're really standing this trip
there they go
that slot jumper
he can percolate
his brother and his father and sister
Catherine Waters he's in a great place
now though nice challenge
Arena where they sold out over 12 000
every game this season here's Newton
battles out yes even prettier how about
that
[Applause]
as close as this game has been since it
was 16 to 12. and we got five minutes to
go for the title here's Hawkins about
that the way he uses the screen
find an opening scores again taking over
this kid he's the one matchup that I
thought would be difficult so tough with
four ball handlers
on the floor right now for UConn nice
pass inside they go to Hawkins
[Applause]